Hey guys, Doctor Berg here. In this video,
I'm going to talk about the best snacks
for low blood sugar, okay? I used to have
low blood sugar and I used to have like,
protein snacks and protein bars and
apples with peanut butter. Well, I don't
recommend that any more, because every
time you snack,
you're going to worsen the problem. You're
going to worsen the low blood sugar. You're
going to become a real hypoglycemic, which
is almost a pre-diabetes situation. So
continuing the snack always makes it
worse over time, okay? We're going to talk
about why. So normal blood sugars: 100.
But it's usually between I'd say, 80
to 90, but you don't want it higher
than 100, okay? And what that means is one
teaspoon of sugar diluted to your all of
your blood in your body like, a gallon
and a half of blood roughly, okay? So
that's not that much sugar. So what
happens when you eat a snack, no matter
what you snack on, it doesn't matter but
protein will do this as well. You
actually elevate your sugars. You're
bringing your sugar back up, okay? So the
sugar comes high and then that triggers
a hormone called insulin and the purpose
of insulin is to drive this sugar down.
So you end up with a low blood sugar
situation. So here you are, eat a snack
wait a couple hours, boom, it's down again.
You got to eat again. It's high, boom, down.
It keeps coming up and down, up and down,
up and down and this is what's happening
to a lot of people and it happens to me
as well. And it just worsens the problem
because they really don't understand the
background, what's behind the scene. They
don't realize that they're continuing
the problem. So you have to, number one,
realize that snacking worsens the
problem, okay? Number two, we have to
change what you eat at the meal. So you
really want to do this where you have
three meals a day starting out -- no snacks.
To do that, and to stabilize your sugar,
you need certain things. One of the most
important things to help insulin be
stabilized and not go too high, or too
low, would be potassium. Potassium and
insulin work together, okay? So yes, you
can take it as a supplement, but I would
rather you get it from the foods.
And you guessed it, vegetables give you
the most potassium. So but, here's the
thing, you need between about seven to
10 cups of vegetable —  or even more salad,
if you're going to do salad, because
vegetables are a little bit more dense,
every single day to get this potassium
requirement. No one is doing that, so
they're going to have a hard time fixing
this blood sugar situation. So potassium, so you, if you, eat a meal the first
thing you do is you have your, your vegetable,
your salad, okay? So if I'm gonna do that,
like I might do a kale shake, well, a huge salad. I'll eat that first before
anything else, okay? That's number one, so
I have vegetables. I have a moderate
amount of protein for with each meal.
Okay, that's like three to six ounces.
Don't want too much, because that could
spike insulin as well. Just a moderate
amount. But here's the thing that is
missing, too. If you do a lean piece of
meat or a protein shake with vegetables,
you're going to be starving because if you
already have a blood sugar problem, it's
only going to last like an hour or two. What you
need to add to make this transition
smooth, you need to add fat, okay? Like
nuts, enough nuts, or almond butter, or nut
butters, or avocado, or brie cheese, or
more olive (oil) in your salad dressing, or, or
butter, to the point where you feel so
satisfied, you can go from one meal to
the next comfortably, okay? So you have to
make those adjustments. If you have too
much, you might aggravate the gallbladder
and cause right shoulder pain and
headaches because the gallbladder has
nerves that run up there. Or too little,
you're just going to be hungry. Now the
thing is that, if someone has low blood
sugar, to make this transition, takes
about three weeks to two weeks sometimes,
okay? So until your body starts to get
used to it.
But once you do it, you will actually go
from one meal to next without much
hunger, okay? And so, I put a video down
below of more details of how to do this.
But even for kids, you do not want kids
to snack between the meals, don't get
them used to that because you're just
setting them up for a spiked insulin,
where they're constantly going to do
this. And, and the problem with the snacks
is their so-called protein bars, but they
always come with sugar.
I mean there, I looked at the protein
bars at the grocery store. It's like all
over the place. Everything is hidden
sugars —  everywhere you go. What does that
tell you? It tells you that people are
not aware of the amount of sugar that's
in the food that's causing this blood
sugar thing. Because if you snack on a
Snickers bar or something sweet between
the meal or even an apple, you're really
going to make this thing a lot worse in
propel it into the future, okay? So a
protein would be the next best thing but
then just to cut it out completely. That
would be the best thing to do. And the
last thing I want to talk about is there
are certain things that will trigger
insulin, okay? Sugar will do it, excessive
protein will do it, but the other
thing, if you combine protein with sugar,
you get an exaggerated spike of insulin
versus eating them separately. So that
would be the protein bar with, with the
added sugar to it and that's what
everyone's doing. So again, I'm just kind
of giving you some food for thought and
to give you enough information so you
can get out of this blood sugar trap.
Thanks for watching.
Hey tell me what you think about this video. Go ahead and comment below and give me your feedback.